but in a way the rise in popularity of
trick-or treat through screenings
merchandising and fan artwork has
cemented Sam as a Halloween icon he's
become an unofficial mascot of the
holiday and that was by Design D
explains I realized that while Christmas
has Santa Claus Easter had an eggling
rabbits and Valentine's Day had chubby
winged children that shot arrows at your
heart Halloween was missing a
mythological mascot I knew the character
must be out there he was just hiding the
image most commonly associated with
Halloween is the Jackal Lantern Sam
continues the tradition as his uncovered
head scene at the end of trick-or treat
resembles a hollowed out pumpkin skull